en este vídeo vamos a pensar en maneras
de calcular cuánto veces 31.2 x 19 hay
varias formas de abordar esto pero como
siempre pausa el vídeo y trata de
resolverlo por tu cuenta
muy bien ahora hagamos esto juntos una
forma de pensar en esto es que puedes
ver 31.2 como un cierto número de
décimas y cuantas décimas serían bueno
podrías ver a 31.2 como un cierto número
de décimas y lo puedes ver como 312
décimas de modo que esto es lo mismo que
312 décimas por 19 y lo que podríamos
hacer es calcular cuánto es 312 de algo
x 19 o cuánto es 312 x 19 serán tantas
décimas y luego podemos convertir las de
nuevo a un decimal también mostraré otra
estrategia pero hagamos esto si
tuviéramos que multiplicar 312 por 19
esto es igual a 2 por 9 18 1 por 99 más
1 es 10 3 por 9 es 27 más 1 es 28 si lo
que acabo de hacer no te resulta
familiar tenemos vídeos que explican
cómo funciona este proceso y luego vamos
a la posición
de las escenas justo aquí y uno por dos
es 2 1 por 1 es 11 por 3 3 y luego
sumamos todo tenemos 8 0 12 28 19 23 es
igual a 5 entonces obtenemos 5.928 ahora
esa no será la respuesta aquí la
respuesta va a ser 5 mil 928 décimas así
que esto va a ser igual a 5 mil 928
décimas ahora cómo podemos expresar esto
como un decimal bueno podríamos pensar
de esta manera si este es el punto
decimal esta es la posición de las
décimas esta es la posición de las
unidades que es lo mismo que la posición
de diez décimas esta es la posición de
las decenas y esta es la posición de las
centenas bueno tienes ocho décimas
podemos poner eso en la posición de las
décimas tienes estas veinte décimas que
es lo mismo que dos unidades tienes
estas novecientos décimas novecientos
décimas
mismo que nueve decenas y luego tus
cinco mil décimas que es lo mismo que
500 otra forma de pensar en esto es que
escribimos todas las posiciones en
términos de las décimas de modo que el 8
lo ponemos aquí y luego todas las
posiciones a la izquierda así que esto
va a ser 592 y ocho décimas y podemos
escribirlo así 592 y ocho décimas ahora
otra forma de abordar esto es
simplemente pensar en los dígitos no en
los números reales para calcular cuántos
dígitos tendrá la respuesta y luego
trata de pensar donde debería ir el
punto decimal así que por ejemplo
podrías calcular 312 por 19 entonces
debido a que eliminas el decimal haces
el cálculo y dices bueno la respuesta
debe tener los dígitos 5 928 en ese
orden ahora en donde debo poner el punto
decimal para que sea una respuesta
razonable y ahí es donde entra la
estimación podrías decir
es aproximadamente 30 y 1.2 por 19 de
hecho si lo estimamos con números
fáciles de multiplicar eso será
aproximadamente igual a 30 por 20 que es
igual a 600 de modo que eso me dice que
mi producto aquí debería ser
aproximadamente igual a 600 entonces
donde pondría el punto decimal para que
la respuesta sea aproximadamente igual a
600 se que la respuesta tiene los
dígitos 5 928 donde pongo el punto
decimal para que sea aproximadamente
igual a 600 bueno si tuviera que poner
el punto decimal aquí eso no sería
aproximadamente igual a 600 si tuviera
que poner el punto decimal aquí tampoco
sería aproximadamente igual a 600 esto
está cerca de 60 si pongo el punto
decimal aquí se acerca a 6 si quiere
estar cerca de 600 tendría que poner el
punto decimal justo aquí
es también una buena manera de probar la
razonabilidad de lo que está pasando si
tuviéramos que estimar lo esto debería
ser aproximadamente igual a 600 nos
gusta que nuestro proceso tenga una
respuesta que es aproximadamente igual a